the jurgen experience or
what like what [ __ ] new movie with
james bond when's that [ __ ] coming out
i want to see james bond win again
i want to see james bond win i'm tired
of waiting you need to be james bond
dude i'm not interested
that's not what i'm saying he's been
dropping these teams
i do not want to be a spy yeah i'm a
roger moore guy i do love those movies
me too who is your favorite barn daniel
craig by a mile really by a goddamn
country mile
the only thing that separates people
from my opinion is nostalgia
if you just looked at it objectively if
i said which one of these [ __ ]
really looks like he could kill people
there's one answer it's daniel craig you
don't really think that timothy dalton's
out there
nuking no not typically [ __ ] no it's
stabbing people
roger roger morris fantastic but you
don't believe that roger moore
is like legitimately out there [ __ ]
people you don't know look he's got that
dead
ken like barbie and kenny listen to me
[ __ ] he's a barbie you got two
options you got sean connery if you're
being dishonest
and you want nostalgia who doesn't love
sean connery i love sean connery but
it's just like the difference between
going back to like
the early days of like jim jeffries
being the heavyweight champion of the
world versus mike tyson the newer ones
are better you might decide who jim
jeffries was the old days
john l sullivan with his mustache how
long do you think john l sullivan would
survive with a prime time
mike tyson how many seconds that would
be the bet how many seconds does he live
from my place it just [ __ ] crushes
his skull look at roger moore
that's a robot though roger moore's a
robot alien you got two options if
you're being honest
it doesn't it's not it's not
disrespectful for roger moore
it's not disrespectful for tim dude i
don't even
know who some of these guys are you got
two options
look at the pixar one you guys got real
sean connery if you're a silly [ __ ]
and you got daniel craig if you're being
honest
sean connery is a wonderful actor
but if i had a choice if i the two of
them are locked in a room who's going to
live
sean connery or daniel craig daniel
craig's going to kill
sean connery i'm so sad to announce
everybody
loved that interview where you talked to
barbara walters about smacking chicks
i disagree that's indiana jones's father
i know
i know like he was great
it was a different time it was a
different time
daniel craig looks like he can
legitimately kill people he's the only
one
like if you asked me if there's a fight
to the death
between all those guys one on one fights
is it daniel craig
he's gonna win i'm so sorry i never got
into that guy
he's the only one that seems like a real
killer he's like a tortured guy
it's a good the problem with this is the
problem is daniel first one is double o
seven
the most recent one yeah here's the
problem here's the problem
it's almost like if you want to re if
you're if you're a person just wants to
look at this
objectively you have to separate
yourself from all the other james bonds
you have to pretend they don't exist and
you have to look at this as an
individual occurrence like him as james
bond is a new thing
let's look at what that is well it
really does seem like there's this dude
who's not perfect like there was a girl
was like threatening him
talking about shooting him in his good
knee like she knew which knee was [ __ ]
up
right he's not perfect right he gets
drunk
he's killing people he's having all
these uh romantic
uh affairs with spies and [ __ ] and
barely surviving
but as an as an individual entity
as the james bond who's better than him
who's better if you really want to be
honest
you you grew up with roger moore but you
knew about sean carter but do
do you think you only like him because
he's the most realistic because it's the
most recent
no no because he's the best he's the
best it's faker
listen to me if he existed and then if
sean connery or no how about this
this is honest if he existed and then
tim dalton came on after him is it tim
dalton
yes tim dalton timothy dawn if he came
on after that guy
it wouldn't work out it wouldn't work it
was a different james bond back then
when timothy dawn was on he was perfect
for it it was like this kind of campy
fun thing where the dude like dressed
real nice it didn't have to be realistic
he always won
ooh smooth spy hollow martini born james
bond and i was like yeah
we went right it was ridiculous it was
like karate kid
right right yep it's ridiculous but
if you came to like a contest where who
seems like a real killer
there's one answer it's daniel craig
that's a real killer that's a person who
kills people he nailed it the other
people are like
timothy dalton's killing people are you
sure yeah it started it sounds like
it makes uh a lot of the stakes
matter here like the uh how good the
movie is
yes at the action movie if they made a
austin powers type movie
daniel craig doesn't fit right um
they're starting to like slow down and
joke and he's right shooting it no no
he'd be terrible for that because roger
moore was more comedic
like remember roger moore they walked
onto the set of the fake moon landing
there was like remember that episode it
was one of one of his movies they
accidentally
burst into the set of people faking the
moon landing and roger moore
i forget which one it was it was that
awesome power runs it no
dude i'm telling you it was
hilarious it was hilarious what was that
one see
roger moore was a different movie it
doesn't mean that those movies weren't
great because when i was a kid they were
great
what it means is roger moore man yeah oh
diamonds are forever in 1971.
so that was before they killed the moon
landing program
they did it from 69 to i believe they
did it to 72. so
rajamar probably was a part of how they
killed
the the the the moon landing progress
except i'm not looking at this is that
i'm not saying that's a kind of how
crazy this is see this was like
a totally oh so this is sean conner yeah
oh it's not even roger moore
oh my god i'm wrong i thought it was by
this time it was roger moore
yeah this was that hbo in the early
eighties
what a feeling it's a bastard he was he
was so handsome
what year did look at that the cops are
running out there and he's got like a
[ __ ]
moon rover he's driving away to get away
from the cops oh he's going to drive
through the wall
oh jesus the fake
moon landing set he escapes
bro this is crazy this is crazy and
there's donuts right
wow where's jackie gleason
i'll tell you boy yeah remember jackie
lisa
and the [ __ ] smokey in the bandit
that was a great clip
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience